yo great uh life moments yeah for me
this weekend we were up in Boston and um
we got to uh got to me50 man that was so
seem so [__] cool that picture when
you grow up in the New York City you
know what I mean like I mean obviously
50 like Legends just musically
culturally uh but like when you grow up
in New York City I know something a
little something different you didn't
just meet him he posted about you on his
IG yeah it was fire man that was that
was so sick but um but yeah I mean we
were just you know we went to the club
and then bro he told me for like an hour
he was just telling me the craziest
stories I've ever heard in my entire
life about like New York Street [__] and
like I I don't want to share anything
because I don't know what can even be
shared now you don't want to
snitch come on get your body out I need
I consequences of snitching on 50 are
way different than the consequen very
true who did I snitching who did I
snitch on you be snitching on just like
the industry or
whatever something like you want to get
it up I'm not afraid of
them but no it was just amazing it was
literally an hour 50 went up and did
probably 25 30 minutes of just bangers
in a row at this club walks directly off
stage and the dove is obviously doing
and so he's like yo 50 wants to say
what's up and they dap up and I expected
it to be like two minutes the club shuts
down the lights turn on they're still
talking it's been 45 minutes it was
crazy I'm starting to get tired I'm
starting like
all after story after Story wrap it up
guys literally I don't want to be rud I
was like can we go home bro the craziest
stories like he's with all of his boys
that he literally came up with like
they're still around there and just
talking about his come up I'm literally
he literally told me the wire for New
York like that's what it should be yeah
yeah yeah and I'm just sitting there
like digesting all this and everything
is starting to make sense like just him
and his position in entertainment cuz
basically what I said to him was like I
don't know how the [__] you do it like I
don't know how you say whatever the [__]
you want and you're Still In Hollywood
like how is that possible cuz usually
when people get a taste of Hollywood
they're like okay I'll do whatever I can
to you know make sure I'm still in this
and a couple things were were very clear
like one when he went up and he did the
show right this is a nightclub he's
doing like an appearance right usually
people phone that [__] in right this is
the and he's way big enough to phone it
in if he wants and nobody's saying [__]
yeah on top of the DJ booth Banger after
Banger after Banger after Banger you
forget like kind of how many hits I I
wild the amount of hits I missed get
Richard di try I was too young the whole
thing is B man you missed that he's a
kid think about it damn and I like
listening to these songs I was like yo I
know all of you know all of them I went
to gym today and I listen to the whole
[__] all the way through crazy crazy
even the sh he didn't play I was like oh
this is another heater y so so goes and
actually puts the effort in where a lot
of like people do like the two cool [__]
but then when you put the effort in
everybody there and us were just like oh
a concert a concert concert like the
[__] Arena tour he's on is probably
crazy the grip he had on everyone in
there was wild too we walked in it's
probably like 1: in the morning I think
he was going on like 1:2 130 something
and when we pulled up it was just packed
wall to- wall and everyone just staring
at the DJ like waiting DJ's playing
bangers like he's a great DJ he was
actually mixing super nice and nobody
gave a [__] just wait no [__] no want to
they're waiting for 50 and they're not
missing that opportunity to be front row
F he just had a grip on him anyway he
starts dropping like story after story
after [__] and I'm talking about like
New York come up real New York Street
[__] like names I didn't even know I had
to be like wait a minute who's that guy
who's this and he'd be like oh man you
need to do your Google I'm giving you
like actual street ogs that if you're
not familiar with what was happening at
the time you're not hearing about these
guys on the news yeah you know what I
mean like deep yeah you might hear about
them in like albums that honestly I wish
you were there for that for real oh yeah
man and um but yeah it was just fired
and like you got to see it it was like
oh wow okay and I understood now like
where his place in the movie business is
because think about it you're a street
dude you got all these like white
Executives and producers trying to
option your life story M okay actually
let me go back even
more all the American Street stories
that have been massively produced have
been predominantly Italian American
Crime right family stories now if you're
going to put out a Godfather or you're
going to put out some sort of Martin
scors movie you basically want Francis
for Copa or scorsi to put it out right
like that's who you want to tell your
story why these are Italian Guys they
understand what it is to be Italian they
understand your culture exact they're
not going to make you look foolish
they're not going to make a character
that is representing you say something
stupid that you would never say because
keep in mind that's your likeness and
that's your identity that's how you're
going to be remembered right if you're
you're an Italian dude and you want to
call what is it you want to call Sauce
gravy not can you give me some more
spaghetti sauce like that's embarrassing
to your culture if it's not done right
if you're a street dude and I and I'm
thinking the next line of Street
crime sagas will exist within the black
community those stories will be told so
I don't think we'll hear that many more
of the Italian crime Dr the mob is kind
of done the mob's or it's either done or
it's or it's like a blended into like
legit business okay you know what I mean
like like now they're doing construction
they're doing whatever the time where
they were coming up the comeup stories
yeah the broke to millionaires are in
the black community and a lot of those
Trickle and mix within the hip-hop
community and let's say you want that
story told who are you going to go to
you're going to go to some Steven
Spielberg [__] that is going to
have you're a [__] and he's going to
have you wearing a [__] red hoodie
the whole time cuz he doesn't understand
Street politics he doesn't actually know
what's going on he's going to have you
throwing up the wrong gang signs you're
going to look goofy he's going to have
you dress and speaking in a certain way
that you don't feel like is going to be
respected and keep in mind there's like
Nuance yeah in there's a lot of nuance
especially in crime because the words
that you use mean something you're
trying to you're in this cat and mouse
game constantly with the police so
everything that you say is probably
specific to your set your crew whatever
it is who you going to go to who do you
want to tell that story you want the guy
who [__] knows how to do it someone
who did it like Scorsese could tell a
million different
stories but if you want to get the
Italian mafia story done right you want
the guy who's familiar with it yeah so
anyway I'm like seeing that I'm like oh
[__] yeah this is that's another like
Testament to longevity like if you've
been in the game a long time and been
able to like pursue different careers
and like be able to like make money a
bunch of different ways and have your
music be relevant stay culturally
relevant for like 20 25 years there's a
reason yeah you know what I mean
authenticity yeah authenticity but also
like just like you have to be shrewd you
have to have like smart BR uh business
Just A smart business brain dude the
vitamin water thing was the early 2000s
we we didn't we had no idea that was an
option to just be like no give me a
percentage in the company yeah that was
insane yeah yeah just hearing about that
I was asking stuff that too I was like
yeah you're like doing all this like a
young age even before that like the
streets of like where are you picking up
games like so much of this is politics
MH he told me one story I don't even
know if I could I don't I want to share
but like it was like a a a social IQ and
a social awareness that was beyond his
age MH like really and I was like where
does it he's like you got understand I
was like 12 hanging out with like 18 or
19 year olds so I I learned the game
young so by the time I was that age I
was mentally already there for
years and yeah because so much of it
like even when you talk about the the
ogs that you're like familiar with their
name a lot of these guys it's not all
just hey let's go out and murder a lot
of this is politics and being respected
by other people and knowing how to play
that political game sometimes the
political game you know requires a hit
or something like that but a lot of
times the
hit is done for peace I know that sounds
crazy but
killing one person might cause less
violence because that person is the
source of the
violence does that make sense yeah it
makes sense it's not just oh I need to
show force and murder everybody it's
like no no that person is going to be a
problem as long as he's around there's
going to be more violence and more
killing and then we can't sell anything
if there's all these people getting
killed and people getting shot up the
police are on the corners it's a problem
so from the outside the headline is like
yo murder and Cold Blood Gang you know
gang members are killing people from the
inside it's like yo we're trying to keep
the the block safe and keep making money
M yeah this this guy's too too violent
it's a bunch of drug dealers going this
guy's a problem this guy's a criminal
this a criminal out we're trying to do
an honest living and sell some drugs in
the corner this guy's shooting up
everybody yeah but anyway just hearing
that [__] was was cool man it was very
cool and and you see it you see why like
he's having success in TV and film like
if I'm an exec and I hear the stories
that he's telling me one I go okay this
guy's got the Charisma to win over a
room right so I can put him in the room
with these people but also I'm like oh
he he understands he's a knack for
storytelling he told me one thing he's
like I was like so what are you saying
with like these writers he goes he goes
don't invent [__] he goes when you're
coming from you need to invent because
it's nothing interesting like you know
me you don't have Source material that's
this juicy with this it's there don't
exaggerate it's already there got you
you don't need to invent a guy shooting
his gun in the air he did it m and I
thought that that was like a good note
yeah to keep it like it's already so
surreal make it grounded in that
surrealness um so that was fire